Épicurien...
Bah ! Il n'y est pas !
Euh...
Je pourrais savoir pourquoi
tu fouilles dans mes affaires ?
Je cherche le mot "épicurieux" dans
le dictionnaire et je ne le trouve pas.
Et pourtant, je ne suis pas fou.
Il y a 1,6 million d'abonnés
qui le connaissent.
Tu ne le trouveras pas.
C'est un mot que j'ai inventé
au moment de la création de la chaîne.
Ah bon ?
On peut inventer des mots ?
- Absolument !
Et d'ailleurs,
je suis sûr que tu utilises aujourd'hui
des mots qui n'existaient pas il y a dix ans.
Aujourd'hui, je vous emmène
à la découverte de la vie secrète
des mots à la Cité internationale
de la langue française,
à Villers-Cotterêts, dans l'Aisne.
Et vous allez voir que de leur naissance
à leur disparition,
la vie des mots
est pleine de rebondissements.
Un véritable roman d'aventures.
Je vous raconte tout ça de A à Z.
Le monument qui se trouve derrière moi
a marqué l'histoire de France.
En août 1539,
c'est dans ce château de Villers-Cotterêts
que François Iᵉʳ
a signé l'ordonnance
qui porte le même nom.
À partir de cette date,
tous les textes officiels du Royaume,
puis de la République,
doivent être rédigés en français.
Toutes les décisions de justice,
tous les textes de lois
deviennent compréhensibles
par un plus grand nombre de personnes.
Avant cette loi,
c'est le latin qui était roi.
Les ancêtres de la plupart
des mots que nous utilisons aujourd'hui
sont arrivés dans les valises de Jules
César et de ses légionnaires
au Iᵉʳ siècle avant Jésus-Christ,
au moment de la conquête de la Gaule.
Les Romains parlent le latin,
une langue qui va s'imposer
sur l'ensemble du territoire.
Et aujourd'hui encore, plus de 80% de
notre vocabulaire en est issu.
Au fil des siècles,
les mots se sont métamorphosés.
Retracer leur transformation
permet de remonter aux origines
de ces mots et de mieux comprendre
l'évolution de leur signification.
Cette discipline de fin
limier s'appelle l'étymologie.
Prenons l'adjectif "curieux"
dont je me suis servi
pour créer le mot "épicurieux".
Tout est parti du mot "cura" qui, en latin,
signifie le soin, le souci. Son dérivé,
l'adjectif "curiosus" qualifiait à l'origine
une personne qui prenait soin
des choses, qui s'en inquiétait.
Et puis, avec le temps, ce sens a glissé.
Au XVIᵉ siècle,
un curieux est une personne désireuse
de savoir ou de voir.
Une personne qui s'inquiète toujours,
mais qui s'inquiète de ce qui se passe
chez le voisin. À l'époque,
c'est plutôt mal vu.
Il faut attendre le siècle des Lumières
qui célèbre l'appétit pour la science
et le savoir, pour que la curiosité
ne soit plus vue comme un vilain défaut.
Enfin ! De fil en aiguille,
de nombreux mots peuvent dériver
d'une même racine latine.
Ainsi, au fil du temps, "cura"
a donné "incurable",
"cure", "curé", mais les mots peuvent parfois
apparaître de façon plus brutale.
Un néologisme, c'est le terme savant
pour désigner un mot nouveau qui apparaît
dans une langue et, comme pour beaucoup de
concepts scientifiques ou techniques,
ce mot "néologisme" est né
de la fusion de deux mots grecs :
"neos", qui signifie "nouveau"
et "logos", la parole.
Avec les mots fusionnés,
pas besoin de dictionnaire pour comprendre
leur sens, il suffit de les découper.
Démonstration :
en 1792, un nouvel appareil voit le jour.
Il permet d'envoyer
des messages à distance
et sera donc naturellement baptisé
"télé (loin) -graphe (message)".
Au XIXᵉ siècle, il est détrôné par le "télé-phone"
pour se parler à distance et tout récemment
par le "smart-phone",
un téléphone intelligent.
Avec cette technique,
on peut créer des mots sur mesure
à chaque découverte ou dès qu'il
faut expliquer un nouveau phénomène.
Alors, piocher dans le vocabulaire grec,
ça fait très chic, mais ça marche aussi
très bien
avec les mots qui existent
déjà en français.
En amalgamant les verbes
"divulguer" et "gâcher" pour former
"divulgâcher",
nos cousins québécois ont brillamment
traduit le concept anglais de "spoiler".
Vous savez, cette fâcheuse habitude qu'ont
certains de révéler la fin de l'histoire.
Je déteste ça ! Ce type de néologismes
qui reposent sur la syllabe commune
de deux mots pour les fusionner
s'appelle un mot-valise.
Tenez, pensez au dernier "courriel"
que vous avez rédigé en "franglais".
Ah, mais ça me rappelle un autre mot :
Épicurieux !
- Parfaitement !
J'ai fusionné les deux adjectifs
"épicurien" et "curieux".
OK, j'ai compris le truc ! À mon tour !
Jouer avec les mots, les remanier,
c'est le principal moteur
de l'enrichissement de notre vocabulaire.
Ces évolutions passent souvent inaperçues
car beaucoup se font à la marge
grâce à de petits éléments
qu'on ajoute en début
ou en fin de mot :
les fameux préfixes ou suffixes.
Vous avez peut être réservé un "covoiturage"
en fin de
"déconfinement"
pour aller à la "recyclerie".
La majorité des nouveaux mots
que nous utilisons vient donc d'une
évolution naturelle du français.
Mais nous récupérons aussi
des mots ailleurs
et attendez un peu
avant de crier à l'invasion de l'anglais !
Pas la peine d'aller si loin, nous piochons
régulièrement dans le vocabulaire
des langues régionales : le basque,
le breton, le catalan ou le provençal.
Tenez, si je vous dis : "T'es fada de jouer
à la pétanque sous un cagnard pareil !",
ce sont des termes occitans
que nous connaissons tous.
Nous adoptons aussi des créations venues
d'autres pays francophones
comme le mot "divulgâcher" dont on a déjà parlé
tout à l'heure.
Mais bon, pour tous les usages liés
aux nouvelles technologies, on a
quand même tendance à importer tels quels
des mots tout droit venus de Californie.
Je suis sûr que le "streaming",
les "podcasts" ou le "scroll"
n'ont aucun secret pour vous !
On ne peut pas empêcher
les mots de voyager.
Après l'invasion des Francs,
le latin que parlent les Gaulois intègre
des bribes de langue germanique.
C'est l'origine des verbes
"marcher", "danser", "gagner".
Au Moyen-Âge, le vocabulaire scientifique
s'enrichit de termes arabes.
On découvre l'alchimie, l'algèbre,
les élixirs, les algorithmes.
Puis, à la Renaissance, les artistes
se servent allègrement de mots venus d'Italie.
Ils peignent des aquarelles,
composent des sonates et des opéras.
Avec la mondialisation, les nouveaux mots
nous arrivent d'encore plus loin.
Peut-être avez-vous déjà lu
un manga en mangeant des sushis
arrosés de quelques gouttes de yuzu.
Les mots en disent long sur l'histoire
des échanges entre les peuples.
Ça y est, j'en tiens un !
Une "gourmaudise",
une explication que l'on prend plaisir
à lire ou à entendre.
Hmmm.
Pas sûr qu'il entre de sitôt
dans le dictionnaire, celui-là !
Et d'ailleurs, savez-vous comment
un nouveau mot y fait son entrée ?
Il y a plusieurs chemins parce qu'il
existe plusieurs dictionnaires.
Le premier auquel on pense, c'est
le Dictionnaire de l'Académie française.
Sa première édition date de 1694.
Il contenait à l'époque 18000 mots.
La neuvième édition devrait en compter
entre 55 et 60000.
Il y a encore un peu de suspense
parce qu'elle est toujours en cours d'élaboration.
Ça fait plus de 50 ans
que les académiciens y travaillent
et ils n'en sont qu'à la lettre S.
S ? Mais c'est après le G ! Pffff !
On n'est pas près de voir
"gourmaudise" dans le dico !
Ils se réunissent tous les jeudis matin
et passent
plusieurs heures à débattre
de la définition de chaque mot.
Leurs travaux sont publiés au fur
et à mesure au Journal officiel.
Alors c'est vrai que les recommandations
des académiciens sont souvent relayées
dans la presse et très commentées,
mais elles n'ont pas valeur de loi.
Ouf !
Je vais pouvoir continuer à raconter
n'importe quoi !
Ce que je veux dire par là, c'est
qu'un mot n'a pas besoin
d'être reconnu par l'Académie française
pour entrer dans d'autres dictionnaires.
Les deux plus connus en France,
le Larousse et Le Robert, sont publiés
par des maisons d'édition privées
qui sont totalement libres
et ne se privent pas d'intégrer
des mots rejetés par les immortels.
C'est le surnom que l'on donne aux
académiciens qui gardent leur siège à vie.
Alors pourquoi certains mots
entrent dans le dictionnaire et d'autres pas ?
Toute l'année, les éditeurs du Larousse
et du Robert repèrent
l'apparition de nouveaux mots
dans un article de journal, une chanson,
une publication scientifique ou au détour
d'une banale conversation dans le métro.
Ils doivent ensuite vérifier que l'usage
de ce mot est fréquent et répandu.
Scruter ses apparitions dans les médias,
la littérature,
mais aussi de plus en plus sur les réseaux
sociaux, c'est un indicateur précieux.
Des logiciels permettent d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui
de recenser automatiquement
la fréquence d'emploi des mots.
Deuxième critère : l'usage du nouveau mot
doit durer dans le temps.
Eh oui, il faut éviter les effets de mode.
Du coup, un néologisme peut être observé
pendant plusieurs années
avant d'entrer dans le dictionnaire.
Si l'on examine quelques néologismes
admis ces dernières années, on remarque
qu'ils ont un lien avec l'actualité récente,
comme "covidé" ou "vaccinodrome",
un lien avec les enjeux de société,
comme "mégabassine", "microplastique",
"éco-anxiété" ou "grossophobie",
ou encore avec les nouvelles technologies
comme "métavers" ou "NFT".
Chaque année, ça fait
donc un paquet de nouvelles définitions
à ajouter pour que le dictionnaire
reste en phase avec son époque.
Pour le Larousse, le quota de nouveaux
mots a été fixé à 150.
Pour le Robert, il n'y a pas de quota,
mais ça tourne autour des mêmes chiffres.
Mais alors, ils doivent écrire de plus
en plus petit pour tout faire rentrer ?
Ils ont de puissants logiciels de mise
en page,
mais ça ne suffit pas toujours.
Chez Larousse,
les mots les plus poussiéreux
sont poussés vers la sortie.
10% des termes que l'on trouvait
dans la première édition
du Larousse de 1856
ont, par exemple, été retirés.
On trouve au cimetière des mots destitués
des adverbes tels que "persévéramment",
"processionnellement", des verbes comme
"monseigneuriser" ou "magnétoscoper".
Je l'ai utilisé celui-ci !
Ou encore des adjectifs trop rarement
employés, comme "zinzolin".
Oh dommage ! Avec deux Z,
il devait valoir des points
celui-ci au Scrabble !
Je te rassure,
il est encore dans l'édition en ligne.
Et puis, j'ai un scoop !
À part pour les puristes du Scrabble,
rien ne vous interdit d'utiliser des mots
qui ne figurent pas dans les dicos.
Les artistes ne s'en privent pas
et les journalistes non plus.
Quand ils parlent, par exemple,
des "trumpistes" pour désigner
les partisans de l'ancien
président américain Donald Trump.
Entrer dans le dictionnaire,
ce n'est pas la fin de l'aventure
pour un mot. Notre langue est vivante,
leur sens continue
d'évoluer au fil du temps.
On l'a bien vu avec l'adjectif "curieux"
et c'est vrai pour beaucoup d'autres.
L'adjectif "formidable",
par exemple, à l'origine,
était synonyme de "terrible", "redoutable".
Aujourd'hui,
on l'emploie dans le sens "merveilleux".
Par ailleurs, nous sommes 250 millions
de francophones dans le monde à parler
français tous les jours, de conversation
en conversation,
le sens des mots continue de glisser
et on arrive à des sens parfois
très différents en fonction des pays,
ce qui peut engendrer quelques malentendus.
Au Québec, par exemple, évitez de parler
de vos "gosses" à vos collègues.
Le mot est employé dans la Belle Province
pour désigner les testicules !
Et ne vous offusquez pas
si un Suisse vous dit "adieu"
quand vous le rencontrez,
il vient simplement vous dire bonjour !
Quant à moi,
je ne vous fais pas encore mes adieux,
mais pour cette vidéo,
voici venu le mot de la fin.
J'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu et
surtout, si vous aimez jouer avec les mots,
n'hésitez pas à pousser la porte de la Cité
internationale de la langue française
à Villers-Cotterêts.
C'est intrigant, passionnant, étonnant.
Je n'ai pas de mots ! Voilà,
il est maintenant l'heure
de tourner la page.
Je vous souhaite une excellente semaine
sur les réseaux épicurieux !